be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today we are back with another
installment of our beyond omega-level
series and this time we're jumping over
to DC Comics and we're going to be
talking about the spectre because a lot
of the guys have asked for him so I
figured why not is it asked I almost
feel like I said asked asked for him let
me ask you something but we're gonna
cover the Spectre now the spectre is a
character that has been around for a
really really really long time since the
Golden Age of comics actually and since
that time there have been a few
different iterations of the characters
so I'm gonna go over each one of these
and then we'll get into the meat
potatoes of spectres powers and feats to
see why it's appropriate to rate him as
being beyond a mega level so the spectre
was created by Superman co-creator Jerry
Siegel and artist Bernard Bailey in 1940
in debuted and more fun Comics number 52
his origin as laid out in that issue was
as a policeman named Jim Gordon that's
not true it's actually Jim Corrigan I
know I told you that regardless
uh he was murdered on his way to his own
engagement party his murderers then
stuffed his body in a barrel fill it
with cement and throw it into a river
dude this guy must've really pissed
somebody off
now when Corrigan's soul gets to the
afterlife his spirit refuses to pass
into heaven which prompted Archangel
Michael to attach his soul to a spirit
of vengeance and send him back to earth
to dispense divine judgment on evildoers
for 60 years now once he gets back to
earth Corgan remains on the police force
and also fights crime as the spectre
later on the spectres popularity would
wane along with superhero comics as a
whole and he was relegated to the
background role in more fun comics
itself serving more as an advisor to a
new character named Percival pop the
super cop which is to say he basically
became a joke character
first of all pop you don't get talked
about person will pop we need to do a
video about him on his self like but we
did you like his own video because just
the name alone here's the thing
comics loved alliteration back in the
day I see like of Marvel Comics you get
paste-pot pete which is a weird name for
a character to have but like comic book
companies love that kind of stuff but
eventually the spectre was separated
from Jim Corrigan and not long after
both the spectre and Corrigan
disappeared from the DC landscape for
over two decades now throughout the
silver and bronze ages dispatcher would
make several appearances both in guest
starring roles and in his own revived
solo series but it wasn't until John
ostriches
on the character in the 1990s that the
specter would really end up being
defined and fleshed out in a meaningful
way and working to reinvigorate the
character often der added to his mythos
by revealing that Corrigan had died in
the 1940s and he remained dead ever
since although he walked the earth
appearing alive to others and even
fooling himself into thinking that he
actually was alive he'd never actually
come back to life after his murder
furthermore Austria under expanded on
the source of the specters powers by
revealing that the voice the mysterious
divine figure that Corrigan had
encountered after his death was actually
the voice of God specifically the Old
Testament God and that the spectre had
been the embodiment of God's judgement
since the very beginning of man's time
on earth now eventually the spectre
rejected the notion of mercy so the
decision was made to bomb the spectre of
with a human host and hopes of tempering
God's wrath and Jim Corrigan was merely
the latest in a series of mortal host
for the spectre itself furthermore it
had been revealed that the spectre
itself had actually once been an angel
main a star that sided with Lucifer
during his rebellion but later repented
for his betrayal and although his
existence as the embodiment of God's
judgment was his punishment he was
actually not the first entity to do so
as he took over the mantle of a cliff so
a DC villain that had pretty much been
inconsequential up until Austrians run
on the Spectre but someone that we might
cover here in the future if there's
enough interest I mean let me know if
you guys care about like a cliff so
which I guess technically if he ended up
taking over the wall of a clip so that
would make him like God's wrath
basically that's more or less what a
cliff so was I don't know let me know
because we did a thing about a clip so
we discuss it a little bit when we were
covering Justice League versus Suicide
Squad which is actually really really
cool to find out that like a clip so is
basically the one manipulating
everything but let me know what you guys
think I'm really curious about that I
have no idea after all it is the beyond
Omega level series so you guys are here
to talk about how powerful characters
are not so much their publication
histories but eventually Jim Corrigan
ends up getting tired of being the
spectre and his soul ends up finding
peace and so he gives up the specter to
finally cross over into the afterlife
now during the days of judgment
storyline by Geoff Johns another fallen
angel tries to gain the power of the
spectre and when Jim Corrigan refuses to
come back and stop it the spectre
chooses its next human host which ends
up being Hal Jordan who's seeking
redemption for his time as a
supervillain parallax which the spectre
also wanted to destroy and so once
parallax was purged from Jordans soul he
sought out a new host but is unable to
find one without a human host to temper
his wrath this
factor becomes filled with vengeance and
basically goes on an uncontrolled spree
of punishment often killing people for
minor crimes and is unable to
appropriately judge the sins of his
victims so basically he becomes a
Punisher is really what happens which is
cool like I need to cover that story
like that debt that run and just be like
Spectre murders everyone it's like the
most clickbait title ever be the guy
just he just becomes a dick and it's
like one of the coolest things ever like
it's dude it's one of the most amazing
moments the carriages publication
history I mean not so much that like
he's killing everybody which is kind of
cool but insofar as he's pretty ruthless
in terms of the role he plays now
eventually the spectre was unwittingly
forced to take on a new host in the form
of Crispus Allen a member of the Gotham
City Police Department that was murder
by crooked cop named Jim Corrigan not
the same Jim Corrigan who was previously
the host of The Spectre but another cop
who was named Jim Corrigan because why
not make things as confusing as possible
right like hey guys so Jim Corrigan is
the hoesley he was the original host of
The Spectre surprise another Jim
Corrigan killed Christmas alum who
becomes the new Spectre wait a minute is
that the same Jim Corrigan as before no
it's a different one but why not name
him somebody else I don't know we
couldn't think of any good name so we
just took somebody else's existing name
I don't know who knows who cares
hashtag comic book logic it's just the
way these things work but anyway after
Christmas allen dies the spectre briefly
becomes a black lantern during the
blackest night storyline but is
eventually freed from that he continues
to be bonded with Allen until the
spectre is seemingly killed by a clip so
now when DC rebooted with the new 52 the
spectre was once again Jim Corrigan
who's once again given powers by an
entity known as the voice and then
tasked with taking out justice on earth
and that's basically it and so now that
we've basically covered who the specter
is and his various iterations we can
finally move into what his powers are
and simply put the spectre can do almost
anything he's nearly omniscient and
omnipotent he's immortal meaning that he
would never die of natural causes
although he has seemingly been killed
before and he can manipulate matter in
reality travel through time and
possesses telekinesis so like I said
basically anything that he wants to do
now since his list of powers is so
all-encompassing the best way to get a
sense of what the spectres power level
is is probably to look at the feats that
he's performed in comics and for the
purpose of this video we're going to be
looking primarily at
pre-read conversion of the specter
meaning everything before the new 52 but
using fees from the specter regardless
of whose host it was at the time but in
even the specter is a being of immense
strength have you been able to pick up
planets and use them as weapons and
create earthquakes in the demonic realm
with mere footsteps he's able to fly at
the speed of light and dodge a punch
thrown by the flash that was said to be
fast enough to throw the planet off its
axis the spectre has a great command of
magic so much so that he can turn people
into objects such as trees and pillars
of salt and is said to be more
proficient in magic than dr. fate who
harnesses the power of a Mesopotamian
God and is one of the most advanced
magicians in the DC universe
I feel like magician may not necessarily
be the right word though because as I
think about this I'm thinking of dr.
fate wearing like a top hat and his
being like for my next trick I'm gonna
pull a rabbit out of a hat which is
basically what cetana does except she
says things backwards I never really
found this Hana to be very interesting
I'm sure the five fan she has might be
kind of upset about that but I never
really thought that she was that
interesting of a character yeah it's
kind of weird I don't know I'm more of a
stickler for the Marvel side of magic
which I know DC fans are gonna be like
boo hiss boo hiss but I'm sorry guys I'm
sorry it's just it's just kind of always
been that way I always felt like it was
easier and far more interesting than
like magic on DC side but nonetheless
the spectre is also able to alter matter
including his own size having grown to
the size of the universe and at one
point measuring his eyes at 23
light-years apart he also formed a
supernova which consists of an insane
amount of energy in the palm of his hand
now probably the most impressive aspect
of the spectres powers and the strongest
evidence of him being beyond omega-level
is his ability to manipulate reality the
spectre has been able to resist a Wonder
Woman's lasso of truth which is capable
of forcing anyone who's ensnared in it
to tell the truth and is of divine
origin not only was he able to negate
the lassos power but he was also able to
resist being banished by Zeus the leader
of the Olympian gods he was able to
neutralize Darkseid's powerful Omega
beams and was able to defeat and kill
Darkseid himself furthermore the spectre
was able to afford a nexus that
connected all of the realities together
the spectre has also been able to break
through the source wall the boundary
that separates the DC Multiverse from
the source of all existence which is
nearly impossible to pass through that
feet alone shows us that the spectre is
a multiversal level threat
therefore beyond omega-level but really
we could start and end with the spectres
involvement in crisis on Infinite Earths
in which the spectre produces enough
energy to destroy all space and time
during his battle with the anti-monitor
which effectively creates the new DC
Universe that would be the new status
quo for DC Comics for years to come so
the fact of the Spectre can shatter and
recreate an entire universe pretty much
ends any debate as to whether or not
he's considered Avion omega-level
character but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are no here to comment explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rod 4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and let me know down in the
comments section what character you want
to see in the next be on omega-level
video and I will catch you all later
purse
[Music]